especially instagram for women like all  the photos  of other women are edited you know there  are some yeah but  usually they're edited and that is hard  for me to deal with  and if it's hard for me to deal with i  can't imagine what it's like being a 13  year old girl now  unfortunately you can't block it because  if you  just shield your kid from social media  they're going to be a social pariah  right like there is an element of status  that comes with social media  so i think i'm just going to have to be  brutally honest about hey pictures are  edited this is addictive  okay like what you're seeing isn't true  and hopefully  people who grow up with it can can learn  but you're gonna have to be  pretty resilient to figure out how to  use social media without it destroying  your life as a teenage girl